internet connection is the most basic
configuration setting needed for a
device to access the web or different
activities
but how exactly do we connect our system
to the internet
this is done by accessing the dhcp
network protocol hi guys and welcome to
yet another interesting video by simply
learn but before we begin if you love
watching tech videos subscribe to our
channel and hit the bell icon never to
miss an update from us
let's take a look at today's agenda
firstly we will understand what exactly
the dhcp protocol is
then the allocation methods in dhcp
protocol
next we will understand some helpful
dhcp settings
and lastly step wise we will understand
the operation model for dhcp
let's understand the dhcp protocol
the dynamic host protocol or dhcp
is a protocol that is designed to assign
the ip address to a device for it to
access the internet
this network model is based on the
client server architecture and removes
the process of manually assigning an ip
address to the system
now let's take a look at the allocation
methods for the dhcp protocol
the allocation method of dhcp is divided
into two types the first type is the
manual allocation
which as the name suggests is the
signing of ip address to the system
manually by the user
the second method is dynamic allocation
which uses a client server architecture
to assign an ip address to the system
now let's see some points regarding the
allocation method
the first type is the manual location
as mentioned in this allocation type the
user manually assigns cip address to the
system for accessing the internet and
can be observed in this instance
this is done by accessing the network
configuration setting
of the device and also requires other
related
such as
subnet mask
preferred dns server and default gateway
let's now take a look at the dynamic
allocation
in this allocation method the client
device receives all the relevant network
configurations from the dhcp server and
the system gets configured to access the
internet
the provided ip address is given for a
certain period which is also termed as
the lease
now that we somewhat understand what
exactly the dynamic allocation in dhcp
server is let's take a look at a small
example
open the start menu
and type command prompt
when the windows open up
type
ip
config
slash
all command
as we see by this command we can take a
look at the network settings for our
system
over here we can see the dhcp is enabled
that means the configuration that has
been used on the system refers to the
dhcp server
and on the bottom side we can take a
look at the different network settings
that are given along with the ip address
by the
dhcp server that is subnet mask
default gateway
and the dns server
now let's continue with the video
now let's take a look at some of the
notable dhcp settings
the first one is known as scope
as the name suggests a scope refers to a
range of addresses that are available to
a dhcp server for allocation of the
client device
next we have is lease
this setting of the dhcp server is
designed to prevent the holding of ip
addresses by a single device
this is done by assigning an expiration
date to the leased ip address so that
the dhcp server has some minimum
addresses left for the client device
and lastly we have address reservation
in this dhcp setting the client device
requests the server to assign the same
ip address to the device
each time the address allocation takes
place
this is done by identifying the mac
address of the client device
now let's take a look at the operation
model for dhcp protocol
the dhcp operations are performed on the
user datagram protocol in short udp
which is applied on two ports under udp
which are both 67 and 68.
the first phase is where the client
broadcast a dhcp server message over the
network to connect with the dhcp server
this message basically means that it
wants to connect to the internet through
the dhcp server
the second phase is when the dhcp server
receives the dhcp message
according to the message the dhcp server
reserves an ip address for the client
and network configuration information
including subnet mask default gateway
and preferred dns server
in the third phase the client responds
to the dhcp server's offer through a
dhcp request message
requesting the offered ip address and
relevant network configuration for the
system
then in the last phase
the server acknowledges the request
broadcast from the client and sends the
dhcp packet to the dlcp client which is
comprised of network configuration for
the client device
with this we have reached the end of the
video
if you have any questions regarding the
topic you can ask them in the comments
section
thank you
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here